gauthier rybinski sans surprise
l'ambassadeur russe auprès des nations
unies qui a dénoncé un mensonge
après cette attaque la nuit dernière sur
une centrale nucléaire en ukraine
oui ce que dit voici inhibe india c'est
à dire le l'ambassadeur russe auprès de
l'onu il ya quand même quelque chose qui
doit nous nous interroger c'est qu'ils
multiplient des exemples alors qu'ils
sont peut-être des exemples à la
périphérie non seulement sur la question
de l'atteinte par des bombardements de
la centrale nucléaire mais aussi des
détails sur la manière dont se passe
certaines évacuations hélas il y a soit
une façon pour la russie de reprendre
certains levier de communication
ce qui ne manque pas d'être
malheureusement est tragiquement cocasse
quand une mine a dit que la russie se
soucie du sort d'un certain nombre de
citoyens étrangers ils parlent
d'indonésiens et de ghanéens qui serait
retenu par les autorités
ukrainiennes
quand il parle de véhicules de l'onu qui
aurait été réquisitionnés sans que deux
véhicules onusiens sans que l'onil soit
au courant tout cela évidemment il faut
le vérifier mais le fait que
l'ambassadeur russe s'attache à
démontrer par des exemples plus ou moins
importants qu'il y a quelque chose qui
de son point de vue à lui relève de
l'injustice ça n'est pas complètement
j'allais dire la même chose que
d'habitude même chose on désigne
globalement la désinformation mais on ne
rentre pas dans ce type de détail alors
effectivement il va falloir vérifier
tout cela mais c'est un c'est quelque
chose qui demande à être
comment dirais-je affiné peaufiner dans
la mesure où si où on a vu dès le départ
que les ukrainiens avaient un certain
savoir faire et même un savoir faire
certain sur la communication
souvenez-vous de ce site qui avait été
qui a été mise en place pour permettre
aux parents de soldats russes de se
renseigner sur leur sort de leur fils de
leurs proches de leurs
cousin ou et c'est donc ça c'était déjà
un point le deuxième point c'est que là
aussi il y a dans la rhétorique de dunes
l'ambassadeur russe quelque chose
d'extrêmement sur surprenant même si on
conçoit bien que ça soit tactiquement
payant il dit à fond à l'occident est
dit avec jolie avec votre propagande
éhontée finalement vous méprisez les
civils ukrainien on serait tenté de dire
c'est l'hôpital qui se moque de la
charité c'est à dire que qui au 6 e s
que les russes préoccupe du sort des
civils craignent un on a vu alors là
sans aucune contestation possible
certain nombre d'immeubles et
d'habitations civiles que ça soit kiev
qui ont été visé et touché mais voyez
vous j'ai l'impression que parfois dans
la bouche des russes quand on commence à
parler d' humanitaires c'est que
d'autres aspects sont peut-être moins
stable où on se sent un peu moins stable
sur d'autres aspects de la question
peut-être militaires ou politiques mais
que ça n'est pas complètement où ça
révèle quelque chose et que ça n'est pas
anodin guillaume l'esconge arias mons
war vous êtes consultant militaire pour
france 24 pourquoi moscou vise les
centrales nucléaires en ukraine le site
de tchernobyl et déjà sous contrôle de
l'armée russe et on a entendu
l'ambassadeur russe qui dit contrôler en
tout cas la sécurité de cette centrale
de zaporojie au centre du pays que
cherche la russie non déjà je pense que
je reviendrai sur ce qu'une gauthier
rybinski à savoir que effectivement la
mise en sécurité de céder ce que dit
l'ambassadeur russe doit aussi être
écoutée c'est à dire que en mettant en
sécurité s'est tenu créé sept centrales
nucléaires comme aussi ils l'ont
prétendu après avoir pris la centrale de
tchernobyl c'est pour finalement
s'assurer de gains qui sont pas
uniquement des gains territoriaux mais
aussi de levier stratégique et c'est le
deuxième point à quoi ça sert finalement
une
de tenir ses centrales nucléaires c'est
d'avoir finalement un effet possible
pour jouer sur tout simplement la
distribution d'électricité et on se
doute que c'est une arme de guerre c'est
une arme de guerre parce que tout
simplement qu'on vous avez une des plus
grandes centrales nucléaires d'europe
qui fournit à peu près alors on dit
quatre millions de foyers peut-être
entre 40 et 50% de l'énergie en ukraine
c'est à dire que vous avez désormais un
levier très net pour permettre le
fonctionnement de tout ce qui est
nécessaire dans un conflit à savoir les
hôpitaux les services publics tel qu'il
fonctionne et puis tout simplement les
outils militaires les postes de
commandement le lien avec l'information
etc et donc quelque part on pensait dans
c'est cette ce levier sur la
distribution d'énergie et bien on change
un petit peu la donne et on force
quelque part un petit peu le destin
puisque désormais battre prenez un
hôpital ça va fonctionner quelques
heures 48 peut-être maximum avec des
groupes électrogènes mais derrière on
fera quoi il faudra donc d'autres formes
d'énergie pour finalement maintenir la
continuité et ça va rendre la vie des
ukrainiens beaucoup plus compliqué mais
celle aussi des forces armées
ukrainiennes beaucoup plus complexe avec
le risque d'avoir encore plus de
déplacer encore plus de colonnes de
réfugiés est donc un chaos qui va
s'accentuer depuis sécuriser les
centrales on imagine que ça fait peur
aussi aux européens
car le nucléaire
inquiète et si et si ce sont les russes
qui contrôle la sécurité de ses
centrales en ukraine c'est un moyen de
pression de la part de moscou bien
évidemment on est en fait sur quelque
chose qui est à la limite entre la
menace qui est vraiment de nature
militaire identifiés et le risque plutôt
technologique et en jouant sur sur cet
effet là on provoque aussi quelque chose
qui est profondément émotionnel on a
parlé de tchernobyl tchernobyl ça parle
à quasiment tous les européens ça parle
au moins autant aux européens que
fukushima parle aux asiatiques c'est à
dire que la communauté internationale
désormais se saisit d'une question qui
n'est plus simplement celle d'un danger
mais bien quelque chose qui est amplifié
par la caisse de résonance de l'émotion
et on voit bien que si vous avez cet
appel à la communauté internationale au
travers d'une réunion en urgence du co2
du conseil de sécurité des nations unies
c'est bien que on a basculé dans quelque
chose qui est un peu plus qui agite
encore plus et qui sert bien évidemment
n'ont pas forcément les intérêts de
moscou mais qui rend publique cette
dimension là est clairement le niveau de
barragan c'est-à-dire de de pari
stratégique et bien évidemment accentué
est ce qu'il ya un risque
juste une petite question de vous les
posez monsieur là ce que vous avez à
c'est ce que nous quand vous nous dites
que cette opération sur la centrale d
apologie est un moyen d'avoir un levier
justement sur le fonctionnement
finalement de la partie adverse que ce
soit ces hôpitaux marc mattera est ce
que pour vous c'est une façon de
remettre la russie dans un camp plutôt
rationnel et est-ce que ça exclut ou
est-ce que c'est compatible avec
l'utilisation ultérieure éventuellement
d'armes nucléaires tactiques ou est-ce
que ça exclut le les deux exclus l'un
l'autre je ne pense pas que les deux
soient sur le même plan je pense que
zaporijia il ya deux aspects sur lequel
pouvaient le considérer d'abord il ya
effectivement cette centrale qui se
trouve à cet endroit là mais aporia
c'est aussi une particularité c'est
aussi un des axes logistiques qui
commande le ravitaillement des unités
ukrainienne qui sont dans le sur les
lignes de contact et dans le donbass
c'est à dire qu'on peut aussi considérer
que la prise de toutes façons de ceux de
cet endroit là et est nécessaire parce
que sans quoi vous aviez des axes
logistiques qui allait encore renforcer
et permettre la résistance des forces
d'ukrainiens à l'est de l'ukraine et
donc on peut considérer aussi peut-être
que c'est la prise de cette de cette
centrale nucléaire est tout simplement
un objectif stratégique pas simplement
pour ce qu'elle représente mais aussi
tout simplement parce que tactiquement
localement
logistiquement est là elle a aussi une
importance et je crois que le lien ou la
déconnexion avec la question du
nucléaire tactique doit être fait parce
que la doctrine russe même si elle est
relativement opaque en la matière
ne prévoit pas pour l'instant des usages
d'armement tactique mais je pense que
c'est à mon avis une dimension qu'il ne
faut jamais bien élément négligé ou
mettre de côté mais je crois qu'elle
n'est pas liée directement avec la prise
de de ceux de sète de cette centrale et
je crois que l'erreur ou du moins la
difficulté que nous avons c'est que il
faut garder bien évidemment une somme de
deux raisons l usage que on fait aussi
l'ukraine c'est de rendre de monter les
enchères pour que bien évidemment le
monde se saisisse de la gravité de la
situation et bien évidemment là encore
c'est un jeu de discours c'est un jeu de
tension ou celui qui rassemblera
derrière lui le plus d'opinions
favorables aura peut-être des biens
supplémentaires un dernier mot
j'aimerais être aussi optimiste que vous
est ce que cette crise que nous vivons
ne démontre pas aussi que finalement on
sort de certains schémas rationnelle
sans pour autant dire qu'ils sont
totalement exclue enfin il me semble que
dans la personne de vladimir poutine
c'est le grand retour de l'idéologie
d'une forme aussi de deux passions
tristes on pourrait dire est que ça on a
toujours du mal comme ça a été le cas
depuis maintenant à les 15 20 ans à
l'intégrer dans nos réflexions je crois
que les
juste un dernier mot la dimension
mentionnait l'enjeu politique elle est
souvent sous-estimée merci beaucoup
merci à tous les deux merci beaucoup
gauthier rybinski
merci guillaume la scuderia ce merci
d'avoir été avec nous